my name's samuel leeds i'm from a
working class background
i became a multi-millionaire and from
doing that
i've learned a lot about the government
about the education system
about the banks in fact against the
system as a whole and i
really strongly believe and i know
people call me
controversial some people even say i'm a
conspiracist
but i'm gonna tell you what i believe
and i want you to just do your own
research
i beg you i plead with you do your own
research
think just think because i believe that
the government
wants to control you government
govern meaning control meant your mind
control your mind
and i believe the system is wired for
you and i
to be poor to be poor i believe that the
system wants us to work
40 hours a week for 40 years to retire
on 40
of what we couldn't afford to live on in
the first place we have the carrot
dangled
you know with a job it's like well look
forward to the weekends
feel good friday why feel good friday
you're still working
feel good friday because it's one step
closer to the weekend and then on
saturday what do we do on a saturday
we we do errands and then on a sunday ah
we recharge and then back to work on
monday
until the age of 67 retirement age is
getting pushed back
pensions are becoming more and more of a
joke and people are getting poorer in
fact
i correct myself the poor are getting
poorer the rich are getting richer
and listen i i i make no apologies i am
wealthy i have become wealthy but most
people when they become wealthy
most people when they become
multi-millionaires what they do is they
hide away
whereas what i want to do is i want to
tell you openly honestly
and call out the system because listen
okay you might
think i'm i don't know why people think
i'm controversial saying this but
why do schools not teach anything about
money
why is there no teachings of money at
all good debt
bad debt no one knows what it means at
school most adults don't know what it
means
the difference between an asset and a
liability no one knows what it means
why because schools don't teach it
now is it the teacher's fault no it's
not it's because
the government do not allow that kind of
teaching to be in the curriculum
so why would the government and the
curriculums
ban teaching money in schools
and you might say but samuel shut up
stop complaining about it i'm not
complaining about it
i've become very wealthy i teach people
how to make money
and i want them to teach money in
schools i've tried i've spoken to
teachers i've gone into my
the school that i went to i've gone into
the assemblies i've i've i've
led assemblies i'm currently in the
process of talking with the ugandan
government in africa
my wife was born in britain's zimbabwe
in africa and i'm in negotiations with
partnering with the
ugandan government to be and i'll say
i'll pay for the building
i'll pay for the school buildings just
let me teach money and let me help
put money and financial independence and
financial education
in the curriculum but why are why are
the government banning
kids being taught the basics of money
instead what happens at school and by
the way the whole definition of
education
and you look it up or you can call me
controversial but i'm just i'm just i'm
just speaking
what i believe to be the truth what i
believe to be facts the definition of
education
is to draw out from within that's
educate
and in schools they don't do that they
don't draw out the excellence from
within children
and bring out the creativity and the
skills from kids
what they do is they cram in a lot of
useless information
some useful but a lot of useless
information and they teach
kids from a young age how to be
compliant
like in victorian times they teach kids
they program kids
how to be good employees
that's it how to get good school grades
to then go on to university to get a
degree
to then become overqualified and often
still struggle to get a job
and everyone just wants a job everyone's
just like i just want a job so they go
through all this education
to get a job but guess what a good job
for life doesn't exist
and i would rather be self-employed than
employed
right now in 2020 because at least if
you're self-employed you're not going to
fire yourself
it is so risky having a job right now
yet people go into
tens of thousands of debt pounds of debt
to go to university in the hope to get a
good safe job for life
and jobs are extremely risky over a
million people have been
made redundant just over the last few
months because of the pandemic that's
happening and what's going to happen is
poor are going to get poorer rich you're
going to get richer and when i say poor
i'm including middle class comfortable
will be a thing of the past
and and this is just school i haven't
even started talking about what happens
when you leave school
when you leave school what happens is
you're then encouraged to work really
hard in a job
to make someone else rich to then save
up your money
and you're then encouraged to put your
money in the bank and they say that
in the bank that's where your money's
safe it's not
your money in the bank is shrinking your
money in the bank
not only is it shrinking because as
inflation and cost of living goes up but
the money stays the same
but also it's really really risky
because
they give you pretty much zero return
and on top of that
on top of that if you've got money in
the bank and the bank goes burst
you have lost your money now
i mean i know people have got millions
of pounds in the bank i'm like are you
are you financially [ __ ] did they
not teach you this in schools obviously
yeah of course they didn't
but if you've got millions of pounds in
the bank the bank goes burst you'll be
left with about 80 000 pounds in the
bank
you know you've just lost millions of
pounds if everyone went to the bank
and said hey can we have that money
please that we put in the bank
they'll be like no you can't have it why
not because they tell
you to invest money safely in the bank
you give it to the banks and then they
invest it and they make
very good returns and they give you 0.5
percent you know when it starts with a
zero it's bad
so so i mean that that that's a scam
if i did that oh my goodness
and the hypocrisy of the banks the
hypocrisy of the system
i mean listen like as i say you might
not agree but just look into it just
look into it i'll urge you
go to a bank tomorrow and say to your
bank manager
i'd like a 25 000 loan please and when
they say
what for tell them that you want the
loan to go and invest
in an investment property it's going to
be a very
lucrative safe cash flow producing
property investment and the bank manager
will tell you
they cannot give you the money they'll
say it's too risky
then go back the next day and say i want
25
000 pounds please and when they say what
for tell them that you want to
use it to get married and they'll
they'll congratulate you they'll say oh
congratulations
when's the wedding and they'll give you
the 25 000 pounds
that's going to be gone in a day on the
wedding day and the
marriage has got a 50 chance ending
divorce anyway but they'll give you that
they'll give you the 25 000 pounds to go
on holiday they'll give you the 25 000
pounds to go to
las vegas and gamble no problem you're
an adult have fun
but they won't give you to go and invest
in property why because i believe
the system wants you poor i i just can't
see i
all of this stuff right from when you're
a kid right up and when
you're old we are lied to we are
brainwashed we're even brainwashed by
the media
the bad news media we're brainwashed
we're
we're encouraged to get into bad debt
but discouraged from getting into good
debt
the media will tell you you know buy now
pay later
you know buy this hot tub now zero
percent interest
and then pay for it next summer in the
year's time and everyone goes oh that's
nice that's helpful
and then what happens in a year's time
you've still got to pay for it you're
still going to pay for it now you're
just winding yourself up in bad debt
taking credit card debts to pay off
bills downward spiral of debt most
people are in bad debt
and the crazy thing is and the reason
i'm so happy to speak and expose all
this nonsense is because
the same people that do that try and
expose me
i say oh this they call me the
controversial property trainer
what's controversial it's just the truth
he encourages people to get into debt no
i show people how to get into good debt
and how to invest and believe believe me
most rich people they have a high net
worth but they have a high debt worth
but they know the difference between
good debt and bad debt and they know the
difference between a liability in an
asset and what the system tries to do is
he tries to confuse people about money
he tries to get people in bad debt so
that they're slaves to the system
so they'll just be a good boy a good
girl and work until they're 67 years old
that's what the system wants us to do
and i'm tired of it and i'm tired of
being called the controversial i mean
what
am i am i controversial i don't know is
this true i think so
let me know your comments though because
i'm tired of it i'm tired of the rich
getting richer and the poor getting
poorer i'm tired of the government
bringing in new schemes
pretending to help the poor when i know
that it's helping me
and i'm rich i've got millions of pounds
so they bring these schemes in
like help to buy scheme it's not help to
buy scheme
it's a sham it's help to sell because
you can only buy
properties that are new builds so what's
happening is the rich developers
are flogging over priced development
properties
to first-time buyers and sucker
first-time buyers are buying it on the
help to buy
sham scheme and the government's saying
they're helping the people helping
people buy
no they're helping developers rich
developers
like me sell i know what's happening
because i'm on the other side of it
i sit on the tables i speak to the
people i know what's happening
most rich people don't say anything
because they're happy because they're
getting richer
you know but i'm from a very working
class family background i know what it's
like to have nothing i know what it's
like to be poor
and i don't care if i'm liked i don't
care if the media crucify me
i don't care if youtube take this video
down they can ban my whole channel i'm
only going to speak
what i believe to be true what do you
think do your research check the facts
and right now all these schemes that
they're doing geez it's so obvious
can people not see through it when
george osborne in 2016 and that's
section
24 and said it was to help poor people
it was to help the working class section
24 was gonna
going to be go against the greedy
landlords right back in 2016
section 24 tax that they brought in i
said it's going to help the rich people
what's going to happen is it's going to
push rents up and and people are just
going to stop buying through companies
and section 24 won't even apply
and what happened the rich have gone on
and got richer and the poor
continue to get poorer and honestly it's
so friggin obvious i don't know why
everyone can't see this
so if someone wants to come on and
debate me if you're from if you're from
the house of commons
or or you're part of the bbc you know
pushing out the narrative and i don't
blame people from bbc
i don't blame the teachers that don't
teach money i don't blame the people
because they're just told
what they can and cannot do but i'm
tired of it so anyway
that's my thoughts comment your thoughts
below
you